queen of Vegas Frank Moreno can also be
called the queen of Dress Up Fashion and
for the holidays the queen of
decorations yep and Rocky is live taking
us inside Frank's Castle this is I've
never seen inside his house to show us
how a legendary Halloween house is done
hey Rocky
okay so first things first my first
question Frank is when can I move in
anytime anytime you would like that was
big enough for both of us to live here
oh my gosh this house is incredible and
I know we are both in our black because
black is in style all year round but
especially during Halloween okay so
let's talk about just your process and
your tradition for the hollow for the
Halloween holiday well it's it's a long
process we start and we just finished it
probably on the day of Halloween but we
started this weekend and we had like
this is our scary section I heard your
partner Alex is a scary one and then you
find the beauty in Hollywood yeah yeah I
like the pretty witch I like the you
know the sexy Dragon whatever you know
like that but uh this is his corner
where he has all these crazy looking
things that scare everybody to walk into
the house and I hear it's motion sensor
so if I do this well
oh oh no it's not oh no it's not working
he's gonna go off just when you go here
comes Alex is going to do it for us
let's take a walk while Alex does that
there it is there it is so that scares
everybody when they first walk into the
home and then
we get more crazy
now this is where the beauty of
Halloween comes in fun stuff oh my gosh
this is amazing but I want I I wanted
you to see that you know like some stuff
is expensive like Catherine's collection
Mackenzie child but you could also mix
in other things to make it fun and I go
to the craft shop and I get like
different things and I add it to other
things and I I build it like I just got
this cute little witch I loved her of
course that's why it's there candy corn
for Halloween yeah and then what I also
love about mixing your excuse me mixing
your expensive items with the DIY
projects as well let's go over them and
of course we do the whole thing that's
the table I put the wreath together
which is a craft project as well
amazing so I just made that this morning
a little pop of color a little purple in
there yeah put put every little spiders
you know there's a little hat here's a
jeweled owl so you look at it and you'll
see the spiders over there and that's a
fun project to do with your kids too if
you got any and now these things we
actually make oh wow yeah so Alex I
painted them you could just get the
crafts and you could have your whole
house done Halloween I love it now
lastly here come over here really quick
we're going to talk about what you're
doing for Halloween yes my last night at
Legends in Concert it's buy one get one
free it's hella BOGO is the code you
want to use so it's my last day in
Legends people come see us I'm excited
it was a great run well we are honored
to be in the Legends House himself okay
so you guys have to celebrate Halloween
fabulously just like this okay